E aí
o Olá eu sou o Pedro Ambrósio Eu sou um
homem esses Branco homossexual biólogo
educador por formação e ecochato por
natureza
alguns anos eu falei com vocês num
evento tedx x sobre como devemos tirar
das Crianças a responsabilidade de serem
a geração que irá salvar o planeta
depois desse tempo eu acho importante
vir aqui e conversar sobre Então como a
nosso papel enquanto adultos Assumimos
essa responsabilidade nós mesmos é
buscar escolhas mais acertadas e que
comunicam diretamente com as causas
ambientais que nos através isso tem
diversas ramificações e eu espero
conseguir clarear alguns caminhos No que
diz respeito ao que se configura como
possibilidade e até como realidade
considerando a atual organização do
mundo e a como estamos acostumados a
viver
o teste escondam vem como um canal para
elaborações reflexões sobre os impactos
do nosso fazer no mundo nós fazer
enquanto humanidade sociedade de
existências e como o bom educador eu
acredito que o convite seja realmente
para educar se
ninguém consegue defender aquilo que não
compreende ou amar aquilo que não
entendi em tempos de promoção da
ignorância conhecimento é a nossa
ferramenta mais eficaz Vamos mudar de
opiniões Vamos ler vamos saber mais mas
referências desse vídeo eu vou deixar
indicações de leitura e demais conteúdos
que me ajudaram a construir essa tholl e
uma delas é o vídeo sobre
desenvolvimento sustentável e consumo
consciente do canal tempero drag logo no
começo a Rita Bonfante nos mostra como
essas duas ideias que parecem estar tão
na moda simplesmente não são reais para
o planeta terra que existe hoje
tô com uma raiva da pesquisa a gente
pode descobrir a definição de
Capitalismo como sendo um sistema
econômico baseado na legitimidade dos
bens privados e na irrestrita Liberdade
de Comércio e Indústria com o principal
objetivo de adquirir lucro Como que o
sistema dominante é baseado em valores
das coisas pode ser sustentável
econômico consumo pode ser consciente
quando é ele a base da economia
eu acho um bom ponto de partida para
desenvolver esse nosso pensamento é que
a gente tem em mente a enorme
desigualdade que existe dentro da ou das
sociedades humanas essa desigualdade ela
social financeira estética ética
Legislativa e dentre vários outros tipos
ela é também uma desigualdade de poder
de escolha e as sobre essa que a gente
vai falar um pouquinho mais agora
os estudos atuais mostram que para
evitar a proximidade de uma catástrofe
ambiental a geração precisa a geração
atual precisa reduzir 75 por cento a
emissão de gases que alimentam o efeito
estufa
É esse mesmo estudo pode ser encontrado
em Forget or showers No documentário em
português é esqueça os banhos mais
curtos ele mostra que se toda a
população mudar seus hábitos tem tem e
quem não tem poder de escolha a redução
das emissões desses gases seria menor do
que vinte e dois por cento bem menos da
metade do necessário isso se dá porque
antes o foco era dado a um indivíduo né
no mesmo documentário a gente pode ver
que se toda a população norte-americana
reduziu a produção de resíduos
a-001 o impacto seria mínimo uma vez que
a maior parte do lixo produzido nesse
país vem das indústrias e das enormes
corporações
é como eu disse não é o primeiro
documentário sobre mudanças climáticas
que causou um impacto significativo na
sociedade foi lá em 2006 tem que por a
War e em um determinado. Ele já colocava
na Esfera pessoal o peso da revolução
que precisava acontecer
a cada um de nós é a causa do
aquecimento global mas cada um de nós
pode fazer escolhas para mudar isso nós
podemos fazer escolhas para que nossas
emissões pessoais de carbono cheguem a
zero é chata
2006 era calouro que ciências biológicas
da Universidade Federal de Santa
Catarina e aquelas palavras do al gore e
curaram curaram na minha mente por muito
tempo e foi quando eu comecei a ser esse
ecochato de hoje já não pensa mais como
um adolescente que estava entrando na
faculdade mas só alguém cheio de
cicatrizes e que constantemente
questiona quais Bandeiras ecológicas
levantar em como tirar do indivíduo o
peso de ser revolucionário uma vez que
no coletivo que a sociedade muda mas sem
parecer que o indivíduo não é importante
né Isso é um paradoxo e como todo o
paradoxo exige reflexão
nós estamos bem com as nossas escolhas e
fazê-las conscientemente de forma livre
é essencial e fundamental para a
manutenção da nossa sanidade da leveza e
da possibilidade de continuar enxergando
beleza no mundo e como a importante
enxergar nos beleza no mundo
eu pessoalmente me faz bem recusar
sacolas plásticas seguir recusando
Canudos plásticos mesmo sabendo com
dados científicos e comprovados que é
popular a poluição dos oceanos é em sua
maior parte causada pela violenta e
legal E aparentemente intocável
indústria da Pesca e
é Nesse contexto o filósofo e sociólogo
Herbert marcuse lá na década de 50 já
sugeria em a ideologia da sociedade
Industrial que no capitalismo as pessoas
que pensa enquanto consumidores e não
enquanto cidadãos a mim essa afirmação
parece muito desesperança Souza e até
triste mas se a gente quiser entender a
conformação atual da humanidade é essa a
única porta para uma consciência mais
Ampla e verdadeira Do que nós enquanto
massa somos submetidos
a entender as diferenças entre consumo e
consumismo meios de produção capital e
dinheiro é um excelente começo para você
adulto que se importa em entender o
sistema no qual está inserido começar
ampliar sua consciência e se você acha
que não é vítima desse sistema você é
sim somos todos podes todas
E para isso tem o canal muito bom
chamado tese onze da Sabrina Fernandes e
que de forma super Lud que ela vai
quebrar alguns vícios de pensamentos
estão tão disfarçados naquilo que é
considerado normal que muitas vezes a
gente nem percebe que tá tão dentro da
gente e voltando um pouco ao saindo
desse vídeo eu os convido a pensar-se no
mundo existem mais pessoas que podem
optar por aquela marca sustentável que
recicl o plástico do Oceano para
produzir sapato ou se tem mais pessoas
que vestem o que tem se ganharem a mais
pessoas que comem que podem escolher o
que comem produtos orgânicos e uma dieta
menos nociva ou a mais pessoas que comem
o que tem quando tem esse tiver
e o poder de escolha Na verdade é um
luxo só é possível para quem tem
dinheiro e no nosso país existem cada
vez mais pessoas sem dinheiro porque
então que a gente continua jogando a
responsabilidade em cima do indevido é
torturante alimenta sociedades e anula
existências a luta Verde tem um lado
bastante anacrônico que é quando a gente
tenta aplicar soluções do passado em
problemas do Futuro soluções do Futuro
em problemas do presente e por aí vai
que aqui que entram nos pontos
principais dessa conversa o negacionismo
apesar de dados Datafolha de 185 por
cento dos brasileiros Aceita Que
mudanças climáticas são de fato um fato
e 78 por cento dessas acreditam que são
também causados pela atividade humana no
Brasil as pessoas responsáveis pela
proteção do meio ambiente são as
principais divulgadores de posturas
negacionismo senão factuais isso é
extremamente sério mas não é uma
exclusividade do nosso país existem o
racionalista CD divulgação de fake News
por vários pontos do mundo elas ganham
força na ignorância é um projeto Sombrio
de determinados grupos políticos
sustentáveis por grandes acumuladores de
Capital que só tem a ganhar com a
desinformação do grande público a nossa
desinformação então se você está
assistindo esse vídeo podemos assumir
que você tem acesso a um dispositivo
eletrônico
conexão com a internet e curiosidade de
aprender alguma coisa Essas são as
ferramentas de mudanças as quais o
indivíduo tem acesso e principalmente
com as quais ele pode ir à luta
questione do vídeo pergunte Leia busque
maneiras de verificar os dados que eu
trouxe para essa conversa inclusive ela
inquietude que a gente se fortalece
sempre que eu trago um assunto polêmico
os meus alunos eu digo para eles quase
que na mesma hora esse não é o fim é o
começo começamos agora
esse essa conversa te tocou eu sou vai
mais fundo escute outras vozes Leia
outras opiniões a ciência a base na qual
a gente se apoia e a partir daí queria
opiniões e entende as possibilidades de
escolha é a partir desse conhecimento
iniciado construído alimentado embasado
a gente pode furar bolha e chegar na
realidade do outro o que faltou para
nossa própria conclusão inserindo o
conhecimento na comunidade a gente vai
conseguir chegar algum lugar enquanto
planeta e eu espero que esse vídeo ajude
a pelo menos questionar mais as suas
próprias possibilidades e também sirva
de ponto de partida para estudos e
ampliação de horizontes o mundo muda o
tempo todo e é só com curiosidade dúvida
informações confiáveis que a gente
consegue se enxergar melhor como parte
dessa mudança Muita gente me pergunta
quais são as bandeiras que devem
levantar ou Quais são as batalhas que
devem travar eu penso que não existe uma
resposta para isso Ou uma receita mas
existem primeiros passos não dá mais
para viver com base em coisas que te
falam você precisa pesquisar preciso
estudar te convida a fazer então uma
lista sobre o que você quer saber mais
não precisa ser tudo né Muito se fala
sobre a liberdade de expressão mas pouco
se aprende sobre como expressar a sua
liberdade sem generalizar opiniões ou
vivências pessoais no tema do nosso
vídeo tipo convida a explorar conceitos
como racismo ambiental que trata da que
o territorial é causador de injustiças
cometidas contra grupos vulneráveis
geralmente durante a realização de
políticas públicas ou obras do setor
privado essas violações de direitos
ocorrem tanto no campo quanto Lu meio
urbano e é um termo que vale a pena se
aprofundar ou ainda nesse contexto
surgiram leituras como sobre o
capacitismo e como a gente deve evitar a
ideia de que pessoas com deficiência
preciso ser incluídas o mundo as cidades
os espaços é que são deficientes e não
recebem de forma igual corpos e corpos e
corpos diversos é o mundo que têm
deficiências para incluir o que é
diferente o que foge do padrão de
normalidade
bom e o que ciência ultimamente tem
falado sobre por exemplo
uso abusivo de agrotóxicos e
fertilizantes e sobre os eletrônicos e
de onde vem a comida que a gente coloca
no prato e o que realmente que tem ali
quanto você sabe sobre a causa indígena
e como os povos originarios tinham uma
relação muito mais harmônica com o
planeta a proposta é usar saber mais é
conversar sobre é trazer para sua roda e
para sua bolha informações verdadeiras e
atuais sobre aquilo que te deixa ansioso
e faz ter vontade de mudança e por mais
Clichê que possa parecer só começa
quando a gente sai do lugar de aceitação
e passividade e passa a se sentir parte
indispensável do maquinário que move o
mundo
E com isso eu agradeço vocês ter me
ouvido mais uma vez muito obrigado